اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في هذه التغطيه
المستمره لتطورات في السودان وفي عناوين
الحصاد
مع بدايه رابع هدنه منذ اندلاع الاشتباكات
في السودان تراجع نسبي في حده المواجهات
في الخرطوم الجيش والقوات الدعم السريع
يتبادلان الاتهامات بخرق الهدنه في ضمن
اطلاق نار في يوم درمان وغارات غرب كردفان
واعلان حاله الطوارئ شمالها
جلسه خاصه لمجلس الامن الدولي بشان الازمه
السودانيه تجريك يقول للجزيره
سيوجه رساله قويه لطرفي القتال بان حل
عسكريا للازمه واشنطن تكشف عن تنسيق
لتشكيل لجنه تشرف على المفاوضات
يصف الوضع في السودان بالماساه ويدعو
الدول الغربيه الى عدم التدخل لفرض حلول
خارجيه
[موسيقى]
الامم المتحده تحذر من خطوره الوضع
الانساني في السودان مكتب تنسيق الشؤون
الانسانيه يؤكد حاجه 15 مليون سوداني لدعم
انساني عاجل واليونسيف تؤكد تضرر البنيه
التحتيه الصحيه ومفوضيه الشؤون اللاجئين
تتاهب لموجه نزوح من السودان هربا من
المعارك
في ختام اليوم الاول لرابع يهودنا منذ بدا
الاشتباكاته كيف تبدو الصوره وتيره
المعارك في الخرطوم تراجعت رغم الخروقات
التي تبادل الطرفاء الصراع الاتهامات
المسؤوليه عنها يقابل ذلك تصعيد اللافت في
كردفان مرسل الجزيره فهذا بان الطائرات
الحربيه السودانيه التابعه للجيش قصفت
مواقع للدعم السريع في منطقه وادبنده غرب
كردفان وفي الاثناء اعلنت حكومه شمال
كردفان حاله الطوارئ وكانت مدينه الاوبيض
عاصمه الولايه قد شهدت موجه من الاشتباكات
بين الجيش والدعم السريع في العرض التالي
نتابع كيف بدا المشهد في السودان في
الساعات الماضيه
[موسيقى]
ليه متابعه المشهد اولا باول تنضم الينا
شبكه مراسلين نبدا بهيثم اويت من مكتبنا
في الخرطوم اذا اوروبا هدنا رابعه هيثم
ماذا في تفاصيلها ماذا في التزام الاطراف
بها
نعم هذه هي الهدنه الرابعه واليوم الحادي
عشر لهذه المواجهات المستمره بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع خيم الهدوء على هذا
اليوم رغم
استمرار الاشتباكات المتقطعه في بعض
الاماكن خاصه هنا في محيط القصري كانت
هناك اشتباكات محدوده في ساعات النهار
الاولى ولكن بعد ذلك ساده الهدوء المنطقه
كانت هناك ايضا اشتباكات في منطقه الخرطوم
بحري في منطقه الحلفايه وقد شهدت
في اكثر من موقع وايضا في منطقه ام درمان
الى جانب محيط المطار هذه الاشتباكات كانت
محدوده ورغم ذلك اليوم كان اقل عنفا وكانت
هناك مساحه للناس كي يلتقطوا انفاسهم وكي
يقوموا بالتحرك وان كان بشكل محدود في بعض
المواقع خاصه في اواسط في
من الطرفين وتسيطر على الساحه السياسيه
سواء كان من قبل الجيش الذي يتهم قوات
الدعم السريع بانها تواصل يعني قصفها
العشوائي وتواصل انتشارها في مواقع
استراتيجيه وتحاول احتلال بعض المواقع
والسيطره عليها خاصه المرافق الخدميه
ويقول الجيش ان هناك قوات كانت في طريقها
الى الخرطوم لتقديم الدعم والسند وان
القوات الجيش تعاملت معها في المقابل قوات
الدعم السريع ايضا وجهت اتهامات مماثله
للقوات الجيش بمواصله قصفه لمواقع مدنيه
واحياء سكنيه في الخرطوم واصابه المدنيين
وايضا بمحاوله تضليل الراي العام بتشويث
سوره الدعم السريع بانها تقف وراء هجمات
البعثات الدبلوماسيه هذه الامور كلها
تترافق في وقت ما زال فيه الاصوات بضروره
الالتزام بهذه الهدنه هذه الهدنه رغم انها
شهدت خروقات ولكن هذا الهدوء الذي ساده
السودان وساده الخرطوم يعني البعض يرى ان
هناك امل في ان يكون او تكون الايام
المقبله المتبقيه لهذه الهدنه مساحه
للتواصل
وبسط التواصل بين الطرفين وايجاد وسيله
لتحويل هذه الهدنه الى وقف دائم لاطلاق
النار ومن ثم البحث عن سبل بديله لايجاد
حل سياسي وسلبي يجنب البلاد الانزلاق في
مزيد من يعني وحي الازمات ومزيد من
الاشتباكات المستمره شكرا جزيلا لك هيثم
من المكتب الجزيره في الخرطوم ومعنا من ام
درمان حسن رزاق مراسل الجزيره
مشاهداتك ايضا حسن بما ينمو هنالك التزام
اكثر في هذه الهدنه كما استمعنا من هيثم
اويت وان الناس بدات يعني تتنفس قليلا ما
هي مشاهداتك
ازاي العابدين الاشتباك الجوي هنا في ام
درمان وتحديدا في جنوب وغرب ام درمان لم
يتوقف وان كان على شكل متقطع اظن طبيعه
المواجهات المسلحون
عن المواجهات المسلحه في الخرطوم هناك
وجود عسكريه على الارض دوله اشتباك عسكري
لكن هنا اشتباكات هي طبيعتها تختلف
باعتبار ان طلعات جويه لسلاح الجو
السوداني يعقبها مضاده الطائرات وقذائف
فبالتالي الاشتباك الجو لكن هذا
الاشتباكات كانت متواصله حتى الساعه
الماضيه الساعه الماضيه سمعنا الدوي اكثر
من انفجار حقيقه كان قويا جدا
لدرجه ان رائحه البارود وصلت في المناطق
التي
حدثك الان من منطقه وان يمكن ان يكون هناك
استمرار لهذا هذا هذا
كانت مستمره وان كانت متقطع لكن انظر معنا
يتعلق بحياه الناس بحسب ما رصدنا المناطق
معينه خاصه في الشرق وفي شمال الحياه
اعاده تدريجيا وان كانت خفيفه تم فتح
الاسواق محطات البنزين ايضا عادت الى
العمل وان كان هناك صفوف طويله من
المركبات التي تريد ان تتزود بالوقود لكن
هذا يعتبر تطور اعتبار ان محطات الوقود
كانت مقفله طوال تلك الفتره وهما تسبب في
شح الوقود وغلاء الاسعار
هي مدينه كبيره جدا وساسعه ومترابط
الاطراف لا يمكن رصدها بشكل كامل لكن هناك
اماكن كانت في الحياه تمشي بشكل
خفيف وفي اماكن ما زال المواطنون يتحوطون
ويلتزمون بيوتهم وايضا بعض الاسواق ما
زالت
مقفله وين فتحت بعض المحال فهي تعاني
النقص كبير من التمويل باعتبار ان السلاسل
الامداد متوقفه منذ اكثر من 11 يوم في
الجوله السابقه في احد الاسواق اشار الينا
احد اصحاب المحال انهم الان البيع يتم
مخزون الموجود محل لكن اذا انتهى المخزون
يوجهون صعوبه في الامتداد الطرق مغلقه
وحركه
ضعيفه جدا صيام ان شح الوقود والادام
السيوله النقديه لدى المواطنين تسبب في كل
هذه ارتفاع الاسعار هناك مخاوف من قبل
الكثير من المواطنين
يشترون استدعاء الغذائيه وينشرون
الاحتياجاتهم بشكل مضاعف لتخزينها مما رفع
من ارتفاع السلعاده في جحسن النقديه على
اي حال
طبعا لا يمكن التعميم على مناطق تختلف عن
منطقه اخرى زين العابدين شكرا الحسن يعني
هو يعني
نعذر بسبب صعوبه اشياء كثيره اننا ننقل
فقط ما نشاهده هذا هو المطلوب شكرا حسن
رزاق مراسل الجزيره من ام درمان اذا هنالك
تراجع نسبي في القتال بالخرطوم مع هذه
الهدنه الرابعه لكن يقابله تصعيد اخر في
مناطق اخرى بالسودان تفاصيل الوضع
الميداني خارج العاصمه في ولايه البلاد
نتابعها في هذا التقرير
لا يصمت السلاح في السودان اشتباكات
متقطعه تتوسع رقعتها الجغرافيه في بعض
ولايات البلاد ليبقى الوضع في دارفور
وكوردفان متوترا مع قتال في عدد من مدن
هذه الولايات من دارفور غرب البلاد
البدايه حيث يقول الجيش انه رصد تعزيزات
واركان عسكريه لقوات الدعم السريع قادمه
من غرب السودان باتجاه الخرطوم
وتعتبر ولايات دارفور الخمس مع قيل قوه
للدعم السريع ففي تلك الولايات خاضت قوات
الدعم السريع قتالا غير تقليدي على مدى
عقدين تقريبا اما الوضع وسط البلاد في
كردفان فيبقى متغيرا في منطقه ود بنده
بولايه غرب كردفان استهدف الجيش مواقع
للدعم السريع واعلنت الحكومه حاله طوارئ
وحظرا للتجوال في شمال كردفان
الاعلان هذا على ما يبدو يرمي الى قطع
الطريق على اي امدادات بالمقاتلين والسلاح
لقوه الدعم السريع قد تستخدم من دارفور
فلقوات الدعم السريع تمركز واضح في جنوب
وشمال وغرب كردفان بالانتقال الى ولايه
البحر الاحمر شرقا يبقى الوضع فيها حذرا
ويمسك الجيش بمفاصل الامور فيها فالولايه
تشكل جزءا من الساحر الرئيس في السودان
وخاصه ان عاصمه الولايه بورسودان تستضيف
الميناء الاهم التي تحول الى مرتكز في
عمليات اجلاء البعثات الدبلوماسيه
والرعايه الاجانب اما الولايات الشرقيه
كسل والجدارف والنيل الازرق في الجنوب
الشرقي والتي تشكل منفذا اساسيا بمسار
النازحين واللاجئين فتبقى في عهده الجيش
وتشهد هدوءا وان كان حذرا
[موسيقى]
وينضم الينا من الخرطوم احمد يحيى الباحث
والمحلل السياسي كون الطرفين
وفقاء على هدنه رابعه هل هذا يعني يمكن
تفسيره انه ما وصل لقناعه بانه لا يمكن
الاستمرار في هذه الحرب
السلام عليكم
مؤكد ان استماره الحرب
الطريقه الان وهي حرب المدن وحرب المدن
حرب تستنزف كثير جدا من القدرات وتحتاج
الى امكانيات مختلفه وترهق المواطنين
وترهق الدوله وتقوات الاخرى المقاتله
مؤكد هناك اثار كبيره ندمت بالرحاب الحرب
متمثله في
القضيه الانسانيه
ومنها
ايضا
القواعد
بهذه الطريقه هي صعوبه بالغه اضافه الى
مجتمع دولي ودوره هو السودان وايضا لكن
الرؤيا على سبيل المثال قال ان هذه الحرب
لن تتوقف الا بعد او ان هدف الدعم السريع
هو القبض على الفريق البرهان وتقديمه
للعداله مع ايضا
شمس الدين الكباشي كيف نفهم الموافقه على
هدنه اللوله الاخرى اذا كان هذا هو هدف
قوه الدعم السريع
هو طبعا التصريحات دائما في الحرب لديها
عده معاني ودلالات الرسائل قد هي اهداف
اساسيه و الرئيسيه
تصريحات هي تصريحات من اجل رفع الروح
المعنويه للقوات وقد تكون تصريحاته سابقه
وهي فعلا الهدف الرئيسي لكن هذه الهدنه
الهدف الاساسي منها هي المسارات الانسانيه
كثير من المستشفيات
يعني
الوسائل
والاجهزه والمعدات والادويه التي يمكن ان
تقوم بها من اجل اسعاف المطبخ حتى جعفر
اولا ليس هناك مسارات واضحه
الاجانب
السودان باعتبار انهم هذه الحر ناخذ نصيحه
الدبلوماسيه وغيرهم المسارات الانسانيه
الاخرى
والدواء وكثير من المراد طبعا تورط وهناك
نجوح كبير من الخرطوم واضح هذه الفكره
الهدنه معروف سببها ومعروف يعني معروف
الهدف يهودنا انسانيه
وقد يزيد بعضهم بقولن مؤقته لان التحركات
العسكريه مستمره القتال مستمر على سبيل
المثال مصدر طبي صرح للشبكه
بان قوات الدعم السريع سيطرت على المختبر
الوطني للصحه ما يهدد بقنبله جرثوميه في
هذا النزاع كيف تعلن الدعم السريعه انها
توافق على الهدنه ثم تاتي بمثل هذه
التحركات العسكريه
وهذا الطبيعي في امر الاحتراف والحروبات
العسكريه وغيرها
فنحن لا نستطيع ان نعرف الداخليه والخطط
التي يعني لكل جهه ان يقوم بعمل
المقبله
ان ان
لمسارين طبعا
هناك اتصالات نوعا ما بين مجموعه الدول مع
الطرفين من ضمن
الامريكيه السعوديه والامارات نعم ارجو ان
تبقى معنا نروح فقط الى هذه الاخبار
العاجله مراسل الجزيره
ينقل عن قاده عن اخبار عاجله من السودان
قاده من النظام السوداني المعزول خرجوا من
سجن كوبر ومنهم علي عثمان طه واحمد هارون
وعوض الجار واحمد هارون يصرح ايضا في خبر
عاجل اخر بقوله مكثنا في محبسنا بسجن كوبر
تحت تبادل نيران المعركه لتسعه ايام
وانقطاع تام للمياه والكهرباء ويقول ايضا
احمد هارون وهو قيادي في حزب المؤتمر
الوطني المنح ل في السودان غادرنا السجن
وسنوفر الحمايه لانفسنا كيف تعلق على هذه
الاخبار
احمد هارون هو
او القى بيان بالكامل متكامل نيابه عن
السجناء في
تحدث فيها من الظروف والمشكلات التي
سجلنا مقرحين وان هذا الامر هو يعني
الايام الماضيه بها ظروف انسانيه به منها
وخرج معظم في سجن ام درمان وسجن الهدى
وسجن وغيرهم وتحدث محمد هارون في بيانه
انهم ظنوا وترادين في السجن حتى يعني تبقى
معهم قليل من القاعده العسكريين وحراسات
السجود وبعد ذلك خرجوا هم جاهزين فتتم
انفسهم
للعدالهم هذا الامر به اولا القانون ضليع
وهو قاضي معروف سابقا ويمتلك من الناصيه
القانونيه واللغه والرفانه لما جعله يقدم
بيان فيه اشارات
الالتزام القانوني وانهم
مطلوع منهم وفي اطارات سياسيه دائما
القوات المسلحه
بانهم ملتزمون لان يعودوا لكن انا في
تقدير هذا الامر كله ياتي في اطار التجار
السياسي الحالي المتواجد ولكن هو امر في
النهايه
اشكرك شكرا جزيلا للاسف انت وقتنا احمد
يحيى الباحث والمحلل السياسي ضيفنا من
الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
وينضمرنا من الخرطوم ايضا عزمي عبد الرازق
الصحفي والمحلل السياسي اريد ان اسالك
بدايه استاذ عزمي على هذه الاخبار العاجله
التي وضعناها قبل قليل عن خروج قيادات من
المؤتمر الوطني المنحل من سجن كوبر ومنهم
احمد هارون علي عثمان طه وغيرهم كيف تنظر
الى ما قاله احمد هارون والى هذا الخروج
من سجن كوبر لهذه القيادات
المتهمه في السودان بكثير من الاتهامات
ومن المعروف بانه هنالك اربع سجون تعرضت
الى هجوم مباشر وكانت هنالك اتهامات لقوات
الدعم السريع بانها اقتحمت سن الهدى وسجن
سوبا وكذلك سجن التعيبات واطلقت صراحه
النزلاء القوات الدعم السريع من جانبها
نفد ذلك ولكن يعني استمعت الافادات من
مساجين من سجن سوبا ذكروا بالضبط بانهم
شاهدوا جنود نقوات الدعم السريع فتحت لهم
الابواب وطالبتهم بالخروج وبالتالي ايضا
كان السجن الرابع المستهدف هو سجن كوبر
الذي يقبع فيه معظم قاده نظام الانقاذ
السابق جزء منهم يحاكم في انقلاب 89 وجزء
منهم يحاكم في
بموجب اتهامات اخرى وجزء منهم لم يعرض لاي
محاكمه ولم توجه له اي اتهامات طوال
السنوات
الاربعه الماضيه وبالتالي كانوا يشعرون
بان تلك المحاكمات وتلك الاحتقالات سياسيه
وان هنالك قوه سياسيه تقف خلفها وقوه
خاليه ايضا طالبت بوضع رم النظام السابق
والتحفظ عليه في سجن كوبر رئيس البشير لم
يكن متواجد لحظه الهجوم على سجون كوبر لم
يكن متواجد هنالك في صحيه
حسب هذا العاجل الذي لدينا الان ايضا
استاذ عبد الرزاق عبد الرزاق
مصادر في اسره الرئيس السوداني المعزول
عمر البشير تقول انه يتلقى الرعايه الصحي
الطبيه في مستشفى السلاح الطبي بالخرطوم
حتى الان هو كما تفضلت لم يكن موجودا لكن
تصريحات احمد هارون تتحدث عن خروج للضروره
وليس خروج بسبب هجوم من سجن كوبر
صحيح طيب لو تكلمنا قليلا عن البشير
البشير عنده مواقف وطنيه واضحه جدا في 11
ابريل طلبت منه عدد كبير جدا وفي سته
ابريل عدد من الدول ان تقوم باجلائه يعني
منها
دول عربيه ولكنه رفض تماما وقال انه لن
يغادر السودان وكانت هنالك المساحه بانه
يمكن ان يذهب ولكن ارتضى ان يبقى داخل
السين طوال تلك السنوات رغم انه بلغ
الثمانين ويحاكم في عده
محاكمات محكمه خاصه بالفساد حكمت عليه
وكذلك محكمه الان يحاكم في تدبير انقلاب
89 اما المجموعه المتواجده في سجن كوبر
فالنتيجه لانهم كانوا في خطوط النيران وان
معظم تم افراق كل السجن من النزلاء
والمجموعه الوحيده التي بقت هي تلك
المجموعه المذكوره يعني احمد هارون علي
عثمان محمد طه وحوالي خمسه او سبعه اشخاص
والنتيجه لانه كان فقط موجود ثلاثه من
افراد الحراسه اخذ الى مكان اخر في ونسبه
لانه لا توجد سجون لا توجد محاكم وفقا
للبيان وبالتالي اي فرق منهم يتخذ على
حمايه نفسه بنفسه بانه هنالك شائعات
وهنالك حديث بانه هنالك غائمه خاصه بتصفيه
رموز النظام السابقه يعني هناك اتهامات
ايضا لقوات
الخروجهمات لها لانها هي التي تقف وراء
البرهان هذه القيادات لا تخضع الان لاي
سلطه نعم
حسب
تصريحات احمد هارون هم لا يخضعون الان لاي
سلطه وانهم يوفرون الحمايه لانفسهم
خروج هذه القيادات بما لها من امتدادات
وبما انه النظام السابق بحسب خلينا بس
اكمل السؤال وبما انه النظام السابق بحسب
اتهامات قوه سياسيه وغير وايضا حتى من
المتحاربين الان ما زال موجودا ولم ينتهي
كيف سيؤثر ذلك على المشهد الراهن في
السودان خروج هذه القيادات بامتداداتها
وبامتدادات النظام السابق في السودان
وطبعا
طبعا النظام السابق هو اصلا الحاضن
السياسيه هي الحركه الاسلاميه والحركه
الاسلاميه متجذره في المجتمع السوداني
وموجوده في كل في كل مناحي الحياه يعني
موجوده كقوه اقتصاديه كقوه سياسيه كقوه
مجتمعيه
ولا يمكن باي حال من الاحوال استئصال من
المجتمع صحيح هي الان لا تمسك بزمام
المبادره فقط السلطه من 11 ابريل 2019
وقيادات الصف الاول كلها في السجون وبعضها
خارج البلاد وبالتالي لا يمكن ان تكون
بانه هي التي تدير هذا المسرح لانه لا
يمكن للشخص انه يكون انقلب على نفسه وضع
نفسه في السجون يعني هذه هذه الدعايه
هذيليه جدا يعني لا يمكن القبول بها الان
الوضع هو كالاتي يعني لا توجد ملازات امنه
وجدوا انفسهم تحت خطوط النيران وجدوا
انفسهم مهددين ايضا الخصوص ظل الاتهامات
الدعم السريع اليوم بانهم يقفوا خلف
البرهان وخلف انقلابه وبالتالي هم حاولوا
يحموا انفسهم وذكروا بانه متى ما توفرت
اجهزه العداله والاجهزه المسانده لا يق
صدون القضاء وشرطه السجون سوف يمثل امامها
وبالتالي هم لم يثروا بالمره وهذا يعتقد
انه موقف واضح
شرك من الخرطوم عزمي عبد الرازق الصحفي
والمحلل السياسي
ومن باريس ايضا ينضم الينا محمد طورشينا
الكاتب والباحث السياسي السوداني وكنا
نتحدث عن هذا الخروج من السجن كوبر
لقيادات من المؤتمر الوطني وتاثير ذلك على
المشهد الراهن ما هو رايك
في
الساده المشاهدين بلا شك خروج شخصيات
النظام البيت في ظل اتهامات الهام موجهه
للمؤسسه العسكريه بانها الان هي تحت ابره
النظام البيض وخلوله بلا شك سيربق المشهد
السياسي اكثر مما هو عليه لا سيما في ظله
وجود شخصيات ذو خلفيه عسكريه وامنيه احمد
هارون عوض الجاز بكر حسن صالح واخرون
باعتبارهم لحتى الان الذين خرجوا لا نعرف
من هم لكن كل القيادات العسكريه المتهمه
بانقلاب والتدبير واداره انقلاب 89 هي
تاثيرات وزاره علاقات داخليا وخارجيا
فبالتالي هذا مهدد حقيقي للمشهد السياسي
وربما نشهد اعمار ربما تكون هنالك تحركات
ربما لديهم تواصل او خلايا داخل المؤسسه
العسكريه فالان كل السيناريوهات وارده
والامر تعقد كثيرا لا لا افهم لماذا
المؤسسه العسكريه او الشرطه لاسيني
والسجون لم يضعوا الاحتياطات التدابير
اللازمه لحمايه تلك الشخصيات وعدم السماح
لها بالمغادر بتوفير كل الوسائل المطلوبه
حتى لا يخرجون يعني في ظل الموجه التي
الان تعم السودان باخراج كل المساجين لا
سيما المتهمين حتى والمدهنين في قضايا
القتل العمده بلا شك السيناريو الان في
السودان يتجه بلا ادنى شكل نحو الفوضى نحو
الخراب نحو التدمير وهذا من شانه ان يعقد
المعادله وان يجعل فرضيه ان يعود الوضع
كما كان قبل اندلاع هذه المواجهات امر صعب
جدا وحتى الدوليه الان المشهد انا في
تقدير تعقد كثيرا بعد تصريحات وزير
الخارجيه الروسي وانما قال لما لا تستعين
يستعين السداره وتستعين الدعم السريع
وبالتالي الان المشهد تعقد واتوقع ان بعض
القوى الاقليميه والدوليه التي ايضا لديها
مصالح للسودان ربما تسلح طرف ربما تست عين
بتشكيل تشكيلات عسكريه حديثه فالان المشهد
مرتبط تماما في السودان بالنسبه للقوه
الاقليميه خروج رموز النظام السابق
والتحركاتهم كيف ستؤثر على هذه المواقف من
حيث الوقوف مع هذا الطرف او ذاك
وبلا شك الرموز النظام البيت باتو معزولين
تماما منذ سقوط النظام وحتى المعلومات
وكذلك شبكات التواصل التي
يتمتعون بها قلت ما عدا هنالك بعض
الشخصيات هي خارج
اسوار السجن كعلي كارديو بعض الشخصيات
تبقى الامنيه هي موجوده بالخارج لكن ايضا
وجودهم بالخارج كصلاح ايضا الذي تحتضنه
مصر انا في تقدير سيجعل الامر اكثر تعقيدا
حتى الان لا توجد مؤشرات واضحه بان هنالك
طرق اقليمي ربما يجعل لدعم هذا التيار او
ذاك هنا صوت الموتور الوطني المنحل باي
حال من الاحوال اه باعتبار ان اذا كان
نظرنا بالمعادله بشكل عام لا يمكن ان نصنف
الاخوان المسلمين او الحركه الاسلاميه في
السودان في اتجاه المطار الوطني بحسب
وهنالك المؤتمر الشعبي وعده فصائل وتيارات
اخرى فبالتالي هذا يجعل انه اذا كان حتى
هنالك اصوات تتحدث بان التنظيم العالمي
للاخوان المسلمين او بعض الدول التي لديها
تواصل جيد مع هذه الدول
ككتوركا او قطر فمن صعب جدا ان تدعم
المطار الوطني الاحوال فانا في تقدير ربما
يكون الدعم من خلال المعلومات التي
يمتلكونها قياده النظام الفائده او
تاثيراتهم داخل المؤسسه العسكريه باحداث
انقلاب عسكريه محمد
اكد ستيفان دو جريك المتحدث الرسمي باسم
الامين العام للامم المتحده ان رئيس
البعثه الامميه في السودان على تواصل مع
طرفي الازمه واضاف في مقابله مع الجزيره
ان الاتصالات الاقليميه والدوليه تركز على
ايصال رساله موحده للطرفين بضروره وقف
القتال اولا
الى السودان السيد فولكر بيرتيس ما يزال
في الميدان ويوجد حاليا في بورت سودان
واعتقد انه من المهم التذكير ان الامم
المتحده ما تزال تعمل في السودان قاده
البعثه الامميه باقون هناك مع مجموعه
كبيره من فريق العمل لمساعده الشعب
السوداني السيد بارتس على تواصل مع
الطرفين وهناك اتصالات تجريها دول اخرى
اعتقد اننا ازاء وضع يكون من المهم خلاله
ان تصل رساله موحده من قبل الجميع الى
الاطراف السودانيه نعمل بشكل وثيق مع
الاتحاد الافريقي ومجموعه جاد والمنظمات
الاقليميه والجميع على الصعيد الدولي
يعملون على ايصال رساله موحده الان ما هي
الجهه التي ستنجح في جمع طرفي الازمه من
اجل التفاوض وتكون مقبوله منهما كليهما
علينا ان ننتظر
المهم الان هو ان يتوقف القتال
[موسيقى]
الهدنه المعلمه في السودان جاءت برعايه
الامريكيه وفي مقابله مع الجزيره قال جون
كاربي ملصق الاتصالات في مجلس الامن
القومي الامريكي ان الهدنه صامده حتى الان
واضاف ان الاداره الامريكيه ترى ان الخطوه
الاولى المطلوبه هي وقف اعمال العنف ولذلك
عملت من اجل اقناع الطرفين بوقف اطلاق
النار
حتى الان يبدو ان وقف اطلاق النار يحترم
في عده مناطق عبر السودان هناك تقاريره عن
عمليات اطلاق نار متفرقه وبطبيعه الحال
نحن نريد ان يتوقف كل ذلك يجب ان يتوقف كل
السودانيين عن القتال ما يسمح بايجاد طريق
لتحقيق السلم والامن في الخرطوم وفي كل
انحاء البلاد
اضافه في مقابلته مع الجزيره ان الاداره
الامريكيه على تواصل مباشر مع البرهان
وحميدتي لحثهما على احترام وقفه اطلاق
النار
نحن فخورون بما قمنا به من خلال العمل مع
القائدين للحصول على وقف اطلاق النار
وضمان ان يستمر وزير الخارجيه برينكن عمل
من اجل ذلك مباشره وبشكل شخصي ونحن ممتنون
لعمله بهذا الخصوص ولكن في نهايه المطاف
التطبيق يعود للقاده من الجانبين ونحن
نستمر في دعوه القائدين الجنرال البرهان
والجنرال الحميطي لاحترام ملتزم به بخصوص
وقف اطلاق النار هذا مره اخرى هذا جيد ليس
للسودانيين فحسب ولكن كذلك لعدد من الدول
التي مازال لديها مواطنون في الخرطوم
ايضا خلل المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه
ان واشنطن تنسق مع الشركاء الاقليميين
والدوليين واصحاب المصلحه من المدنيين
السودانيين للمساعده في انشاء لجنه
للاشراف على مفاوضات وقف الاعمال القتاليه
بالسودان
بعد عمليه الاجلاء الناجحه لموظفي سفارتنا
بالخرطوم نعمل على خطين متوازيين الاول هو
مساعده الامريكيين في السودان والتنسيق مع
حلفائنا وشركائنا بشان الجهود المبذوله
لتامين مواطنيهم والخط الثاني يتمثل في
الضغط على الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع لتنفيذ وقف اطلاق النار والالتزام
به بشكل كامل والسماح بوصول المساعدات
الانسانيه دون عوائق كما اننا ننسق مع
الشركاء الاقليميين والدوليين واصحاب
المصلحه من المدنيين السودانيين للمساعده
في انشاء لجنه للاشراف على المفاوضات
وابرامي وتنفيذ وقف دائم للاعمال العدائيه
ومن واشنطن ينضم الينا السفير تيبورناجي
المساعد السابق لوزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
للشؤون الافريقيه من هم الشركاء الذي ربما
تكون منهم واشنطن لجنه للاشراف على
مفاوضات وقف القتال
هذا سؤال ممتاز لان الجميع يقول انهم
يريدون السلام ويريدون توقف القتال لكن في
نفس الوقت كما هو حال الجيرانهم يتمتعون
بعلاقات معقده للغايه بالتالي لدينا
الاتحاد الافريقي ولدينا ايجاد وهي منظمه
اقليميه وايضا لدينا الدول الشرق الاوسط
المملكه العربيه السعوديه الامارات لدينا
مصر ايضا بالتالي هنالك عدد كبير من
الشركاء المحتمرين لكن المشكله هي ان
جنرالان
الاساسيين عليهما ان يتوقفا عن القتال
لانه هنالك ماما زاد عدد الشركاء في انحاء
العالم لكن هذا الامر لن يحقق فرقا اذا لم
تكن هنالك اراده من قبلهما لماذا طلبت
واشنطن ايضا من اسرائيل اذا كان هنالك
وفره في الشركاء لماذا طلبت من اسرائيل ان
تساعد في اقناعهما
بوقف القتال
اعتقد ان الامر يتعلق بالطلب من الجميع من
له نفوذ وكما نعرف وبوجود اتفاق ابراهام
فان اسرائيل مؤخرا قامت
بايجاد علاقات جيده مع السودان واشنطن
ستطلب من اي شخص ومن اي طرف لانه ليس
هنالك اي اجابات سهله والجميع يبحث عن حل
لهذه الازمه
ماذا واشنطن المشغوله مع الصين المجهوله
في اوكرانيا
معنيه
بالوصول الى حل سريع ووقف سريع للقتال في
السودان
اعتقد ان هنالك حاجه ملحه للوصول الى وقف
فوري لاطلاق النار كانت هنالك عده محاولات
والامل ان وقفت اطلاق النار بامكانه ان
يتمدد لكن الامر يعود الى مشكله ان
الجنرلين يتقاتلان عليهما ان يكون لهما
سبب للموافقه على وقف لاطلاق النار لانهم
لديهم مشاكل في مساله القياده والسيطره
الى لم يكن هنالك شخص في وضع ضعيف ربما او
ربما يحرز احدهما سبقا عسكريا لا اعتقد ان
اي احد منهما سيكون مهتما بوقف طويل للمدى
القتال هل واشنطن
تملك في هذا الصراع
رفاهيه الحياه بالنظر لوجود فاجنر في في
هذا الصراع بحسب تصريحات وزير الخارجيه
الروسي
حقيقه الامر ان ليس اي ملج عليه هو ملاك
لكن ما نقوله ما قلته صحيح اذا ان مجموعه
فاقلار لديها علاقات مع جنرال احمد تي
بالتالي واشنطن قد لا ترغب برؤيه الجنرال
الحمتي يكون يخرج منتصره لكن كما قلت نحن
لا نتعامل مع ملكين هنا
اشكرك شكرا جزيلا من واشنطن سفير المساعد
السابق لوزير الخارجيه الامريكيه للشؤون
الافريقيه
هكذا وزير الخارجيه الروسي ان شركه فاجن
الروسيه توفر خدماتها في السودان ومالي
وجمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى وعدد من البلدان
الاخرى وقال لظروف ان هذه الدول لها الحق
في استئجار خدمات شركه خاصه واشار الى
وجود العديد من الشركات المماثله
الامريكيه والفرنسيه والبريطانيه
ومعنا بالموسكو
محرر الشؤون الدوليه بصحيفه كوميرسنت ومع
ذلك يقول الرئيس يقول
سروف انه ينبغي على الغرب الا يتدخل في
هذا الصراع مع الاعتراف بوجودر في السودان
وغيرها من الدول الافريقيه هل كيف يمكن
فهم هذا الموقف الروسي
تعني ابدا بالقول ان مجموعه
فاقنار العسكريه هي لا ليست ناشطه في
السودان هذا الشيء تردد في الاخبار وليس
هنالك اي تقارير تتمتع بمصداقيه الروسي
اسمحلي وزير الخارجيه الروسي قال انها
تقدم خدماتها في السودان
يعني هذه ليست اخبار هذا اقرار رسمي روسي
اليوم اليوم
دعنا نتفادى الارباك كان اليوم في تصريح
من وهو
مالك
وقد تحض كل التقارير حول مساله نشاطي في
السودان انا اطلب منك ان تتاكد من المصادر
التي
اشرت اليها قال بشكل واضح انهم عذرا
المقاطعه مره اخرى انا لم اذهب الى اي
مصادر نحن اذعنا قبل قليل ما قاله وزير
الخارجيه الروسي هذه ليست مصادر
وزير الخارجيه الروسي يعتبر كلامه غير
دقيق حينما يقول ان شركه فاجنر الروسيه
توفر خدماتها في السودان ومالي وجمهوريه
افريقيا الوسطى وعدد من البلدان الاخرى
الابروف غير دقيق
ان لم
اسمع باي من هذه التصريحات ربما قد اسيء
فهمها وتفسيرها واعمل انك ستوافق ان تكافل
وهو رئيس فاجنا يعرف ما الذي
تقوم به قواته وما لا تقوم به بالتالي انا
اطلب منك ان يتم الاشاره الى تصريحاتي
انا لا ارى هذا الامر الذي تشير اليه
لكنني اعتقد ان هنالك ربما اساءه لتفسيره
تصريحات السيد الافراد صدقني لا تخفي اي
حقيقه هم
ولا ارى اي سبب لعدم
الثقه بتصريحاتي برئيس رئيس مجموعه ولا
ارى ايضا اي سبب لعدم ثقتك بتصريحات وزير
الخارجيه الروسيه لكن دعنا نعبر هذه
النقطه ما هو الموقف الروسي مما يجري في
السودان
انها روسيا لا تتدخل في السودان هذه هي
النقطه الاولى النقطه الثانيه بروسيا تاسف
بشكل كبير لما يحصل في السودان روسيا هي
تدعو كل كل الطرفين في السودان ان لا
يكونان
منخرطين في هذا القتال العنيف واريد ان
اضيف اذا كما تعرفون فان السودان لديها
تاريخ طويل لهذا النظام مع المجموعات التي
تحاول ان تحظى بمواقف افضل بالتالي
لسوء السودان هو يمثل نقطه حيث ان هنالك
الكثير من المصالح
المتصادمه للقوى الاقليميه هناك اشكرك
شكرا جزيلا
محرر الشؤون الدوليه بصحيفه كوميرسنت شكرا
جزيلا
نعود الى الاخبار العاجله التي وضعناها
قبل قليل فقد افاد مراسله الجزيره في
السودان بخروج قياده من النظام المعزولي
من سجن كوبر وعلى راسهم النائب الاول
السابق علي عثمان طه
ومساعدو البشير احمد هارون وعوض الجار
ونافع علي نافع اضافه لرئيس البرلمان
السابق الفاتح عز الدين بينما قالت مصادره
في اسره الرئيس المعزول عمر البشير انه
ونائبه بكري حسن صالح او وزير الدفاع
السابق عبد الرحيم محمد حسين يتلقون
الرعايات الطبيه في مشفى السلاح الطبي حتى
هذه اللحظه
وينضم الينا من الخرطوم مدير مكتب الجزيره
المسلمي الكباشي ما معنى خروج هذه
الخيارات الوازله من قيادات المؤتمر
الوطني المنحل
نعم
البيان الذي اذاعه احمد هارون نيابه عن
هذه القيادات
ذكر فيه ان الظروف التي كانت في السجن
مستحيل ان يستمرون فيها اذ ظلوا تحت تقاطع
النيران كما قال لمده تسعه ايام وفي ظروف
صعبه في السجن لا كهرباء ولا طعام حتى ان
بعض الناس في السجون ماتوا وبعضهم مرض
وظلهم كذلك حتى خرج اخر سجين وظل معهم
عشره فقط من حراس السجن وحينها قرر هؤلاء
الحراس
باتفاق معهم قرروا ان ياخذوهم الى مكان
امن في انتظار ان ياتيهم اذنه قضائي
بالاطلاق صلاحهم او ان يظلوا في هذا
المكان الامن ولم ياتي هذا السجن
الاذن القضائي وضلوا كذلك معهم فقط في
المكان الامن ثلاثه من الحراس من العشره
الذين كانوا معهم في السجن واخ قرروا ان
يخرجوا لانهم لم يجدوا غير هذا المكان
الذي لم يكن امنا كما قال من حيث الطعام
والشراب والرعايه واخيرا قرروا الاندماج
فيما سماه معرفه الكرامه في مواجهه مشروع
اسري يطيح يريد ان يطيح بالسودان وقال
انهم هم على استعداد الاستجابه متى ما كان
الراي القضاء او نداء القضاء او دعوه
القضاء وعلى كل حال من الواضح ان الحاله
التي نشات على اثر الحرب بين الدعم السريع
والجيش السوداني احدثت هذه هذا الذي جرى
لان السجون كلها اطلقت
هنالك اتهامات طبعا بين الطرفين الجيش
اتهم الدعم السريع بانه الطغى صراح
السجناء في سجن الهدى واطلق سراح السجناء
في سجن سوبا وكذلك في السجن النساء
بامدرمان وفي سجن كوبر اذا الان معظم على
الاقل في العاصمه
المتحاربين اصرارهم على ان يتخذوا من حاله
الفوضى سلاح ضاقت على الجيش
وحكومته القائمه بالطبع وعلى الواقع
الواقع الاجتماعي الاقتصادي الامني كله
وبالتالي من خلاله يستطيعون تحقيق اهدافهم
في هذه الحرب الان اعلن هو انه سيكونون
جزء من هذه المعركه التي اسماها معرفه
الكرامه في مواجهه مشروعه اسري يريد ان
يطيح بالسودان
وقالوا انهم يستجيبون لاول نداء لهم
للعوده الى السجن او العوده الى
القضاء لمواجهه مصيرهم وعلى كل حال الى
الان لم تستفيد لم تستبين الى الان اهداف
الحقيقيه او التداعيات والتفاعلات لهذا
لهذا الموقف لكن مساله الاندماج في معركه
الكرامه ضد المشروع الاسري اذا اردنا ان
نفهم ذلك كيف نفهم
من الواضح ان
القناعات التي يعيشها هؤلاء في السجن ان
هنالك انقلاب حدث في في 11 ابريل 2019
يعني هم لا يؤمنون فقط بان الذي حدث هو
استجابه للثوره ولكن يقولون ان ما حدث هو
انقلاب عسكري على حكمهم على حكم ثوره
الانقاذ في 11 ابريل 2019 وقد ظلوا فيها
في السجن طوال هذه السنوات بناء على هذه
الخطوه الخطوه الانقلابيه كما يسمونها
ولكن في نظرهم فيما يقولون حسب البيان
الذي اصدره احمد هارون الان باسمهم جميعا
يقولون ان الامور تطورت بحيث ان ليس فقط
الجيش هو الذي يحدث الانقلابات ويسيطر على
البلاد ولكن
تطورت قوه جديده هي قوه دعم السريع وفي
نظرهم كما قالوا قوه دعم السريع هي مشروع
اسري لال دغلو لمحمد حمدان دقلو واخيه
عبر هذا المشروع حكم البلاد وله كما
يقولون امتدادات هذا المشروع له امتدادات
خارجيه تريد ان تتحكم في المسارات
والمسارات ومصائر السودان وتريد ان
توقع نفوذا نفوزا على الحكم القادم في
السودان او الحكم الحالي وبالتالي في
رايهم ما يجري الان هو معركه بين مشروع
الاسري هذا وخلفه من يؤيدونه ومن يساندونه
ومن يدعمونه والجيش السوداني وفي هذه
الحاله بالرغم من قولهم ان ما تم في 11
ابريل هو انقلاب على نظام حكمهم ولكن
بالرغم من ذلك يرون ان يجب ان يقفوا مع
الجيش السوداني مهما يكون هو الجيش القومي
في نظرهم في مواجهه مشروع يرونه مشروعا
اسريا وبالتالي المقصود بمعركه الكرامه
هنا هو معركه الجيش مع الدعم السريع
نعم هو ليس المسمى ليس منهم هم المسمى
انطلق هذا الشعار معركه الكرامه انطلق من
اليوم الاول وهو صك صكاه الجيش في معركته
تجاه الدعم السريع وتبناه كثير من
المؤيدين للجيش في هذه المعركه يسمونها
معركه الكرامه وجاؤواهم جريا على هذا
المسمى الذي وجدوه امامهم بالطبع منذ بدا
هذه الحرب بين الجيش والدعم السريع معركه
الكرامه هي هذا مسمى الذي هذا الشعار الذي
اصبح
شعار الجيش في خوض هذه المعركه
مسلمه فيما يتعلق
بالقوات المسلحه هل هنالك اي تصريحات
تفسر وجود هؤلاء في مكان تمكن من من
الخروج من السجن بحراسه عشره حراس الى
مكان امن
بدل ان يذهبوا مثلا الى احد معسكرات الجيش
ومعسكرات الجيوش في كل مكان بها اماكن
للاحتجاز
هذا قرار اتخذته سلطه الجيش الحاكمه ان
حولتهم من سجن كوبر الذي لم يعد مطاطا لم
يعد سجنا اصلا بالمعنى بمعنى انه اصبح
فارغا من السجناء واصبح فارقا من من من
المؤن التي يمكن ان يعاش عليها واصبح ظروف
الحياه فيه قاسيه كما قال او صعبه حقيقه
بل مستحيل كما قال البيان الذي قال به
احمد هارون لا ماء لا كهرباء لا طعام لا
رعايه صحيه وبالتالي لم يعد مكان مناسب
للحياه وبذلك قرروا نقلهم كما قالوا لمكان
امن لكن يبدو انها حتى هذا المكان الامن
لم يعد امنا ولذلك
ومن الواضح ان
الشرطه لا تستطيع مسيره انتقالاتهم من
مكان الى مكان بدليل ان الذين كانوا معهم
في السجن اولا عشره ثم اصبحوا ثلاثه
وبالتالي قرر هؤلاء ويبدو انه باتفاق بينه
وبين الذين كانوا يحرسونهم ان يذهبوا الى
مكان امن اخر يقررونه هم ولذلك اسال عن
موقف الجيش الموقف الذي هو موقف الجيش من
خروج هؤلاء المساجين المهمين وهي قيادات
وازنه في المؤتمر الوطني السابق ما هو ما
هل هنالك اي موقف من قبل القوات المسلحه
بشان خروج هؤلاء
الى الان لم يعلن يعلن الجيش موقفا محددا
تجاه هذه الخطوه التي اتخذها هولاء
المساجين ولكن نتوقع ان تكون هنالك رده
فعل للجيش اما ان يعيدونهم الى السجن مره
اخرى او ان يضعونهم مره اخرى مجتمعين في
مكان امن هذا ما نظن انه يمكن ان يحدث
ولكن رسميا لم يتخذ الجيش ولم يعلن الجيش
موقفا من هذه الخطوه التي كانت مفاجاه
للجميع قبل قليل لكن حتى الان الجيش لا
يعلم مكانه لانهم قالوا انهم سيوفرون
الحمايه لانفسهم هل من الممكن ان يصل الى
مكانهم بهذه السهوله في ظل هذه الفوضى
الموجوده في السودان
اذا اعتمد الجيش ان يصل الى مكانهم
بامكانته الذاتيه ربما في ظل هذه الفوضى
الجيش الان منشغل جدا بمعركته مع الدعم
السريع وكل التفكير وكل الاسلحه سواء
اسلحه الاسلحه الحقيقيه الاسلحه الذقائر
وادوات الحروب المختلفه او حتى الاسلحه
الذهنيه والاسلحه التامينيه موجهه كلها
الى المعركه التي تدور الان مع الدعم
السريع ولكن ربما لا يستطيع في ظل هذه
الاوضاع ان يتفرغ للبحث عنهم في مكان ما
قرروا ان يكونوا فيه وهم ولكن يبدو لي
يمكن ان تحدث اتصالات بينهم والجيش حسب
البيان انهم ليسوا هاربين ليسوا خارجين من
من السجن غروبا ولكن الاوضاع التي كانت في
السجن لا تتناسب والحياه لا يستطيعون او
لا يستطيع حي ان يعيش في الظروف التي كانت
قالوا كما
ربما ابقى معنا ساعود اليه لكن دعنا نستمع
الى ما قاله احمد هارون القيادي في حزب
نظام عمر البشير الذي دعا السودانيين
للالتفاف حول الجيش قال انه يقف معهم ضد
ما سماه مشروعا اسريا لاختطاف الوطن بدعم
اقليمي ودولي
يخاطبكم اليوم
وبلادنا تشهد احداثا عصيبه
لم تشهدها البلاد على مر تاريخها الحديث
ونؤكد وقوفنا معكم في خندق الوطن لمنع
اختطافه لصالح مشروع اسري مدعوم دوليا
واقليميا
متجاوزين في هذا الموقف كل ما حدث منذ
انقلاب 11 ابريل 2019
حيث اتخذنا وقتها قرارا التاريخي بان
الحفاظ على كيان الوطن مقدما على اي مشروع
سياسي او كيان حزبي او اي مكاسب سياسيه
وان دماء ابناء وبنات السودان تستحق ان
تصام والا تكون ثمنا لاي نزاع حول السلطه
نقول ذلك باقوى العبارات رغم
وظلم سلطه انقلاب 11 ابريل 2019 بما في
ذلك
طلبا لرضا سياسيه واخرى اقليميه ودوليه
ثبت الان انها العدو الاول للشعب السوداني
وللسلطه القائمه ولقواته المسلحه فهي من
تسببت في الحرب الدائره الان
ونفرغ تماما ما بين القائمين على تلك
السلطه ومؤسسات الدوله الوطنيه وفي
مقدمتها قواتنا المسلحه التي تقاتل بشرف
وبشجاعه وبساله كالعثم بها دوما وندعو كل
جماهير شعبنا وعضويتنا لمزيد من الالتفاق
حولها ومساندتها واستراح المبادرات التي
تسند دورها الوطني الذي تقوم به الان
اذا هذا تصريح احمد هارون باسم المجموعه
التي خرجت من سجن كوبر من اعضاء النظام
السابق واعود مره اخرى الى المسله الكباشي
واضح جدا
الاصطفاف في صف القوات المسلحه والجيش هل
هل هذا بالنسبه للسيد البرهان يعتبر دعما
ام انه يسبب له بعض المشكلات بالنظر الى
حاله الرفض للنظام السابق داخل اوساط
السودانيين
ان هذا البيان
ركز على مبادئ يؤمن بها هؤلاء من ذلك
قالوا انهم تجاوزوا حاله الظلم وحاله
الانقلاب الذي تم عليهم للحفاظ على كيان
الوطن هذا من خلال التصرف الذي تصرفوه
ابانا الانقلاب وقالوا اننا نفرق حسب هذا
البيان بين المؤسسات التي تستغلها السلطه
وبين مؤسسات الدوله مؤسسات وجود كيان
الدوله وبذلك هم يقفون الان كما قالوا مع
كيان الدوله ويتهمون قوه اقليميه ودوليه
وقوى محليه بانها هي التي تسببت في هذه
الحرب وانهم هذه الحرب تهدد كيان الوطن
وبالتالي يدعونا
انصارهم للوقوف مع الجيش في معركه الكرامه
هذا هذا نوع من التفريق بين بين الحراك
السياسي وقوه السياسيه والاختلا السياسيه
مجتمعه وبين الجيش كعمود عمود بقاء للوطن
هم كما افهم من هذا الكلام ان ان
الوطن مهدد وليس هنالك مؤسسه الان سياسيه
تستطيع الحفاظ على هذا الوطن غير الجيش
هذا ما افهمه من هذا الكلام ومن الواضح ان
من الواضح ان التحليل الذي
ارتكز عليه موقفه منذ منذ ما اسموهم
انقلاب 11 ابريل 2019 لا يزال مستمرا ان
الانقلاب كان على خصما خصما عليهم وكان
ظلما لهم ولكن مع ذلك مواجهه الانقلاب من
خلال مواجهه الجيش تعني اضعاف الكيان
الوطني وبالتالي وبالتالي تعريض الكيان
الوطني لمهددات وجود وبالتالي هم الان
يقفون هذا الموقف الذي ذكروه ولكن بالطبع
بالنسبه للبرهان هذا هذا الموقف هذا ربما
شعبيا يدعم الجيش ولكن بالنسبه للبرهان
الذي يقول انه ملتزم بثوره 19 ثوره ديسمبر
وانه
لا يزال على موقفه في وضعهم في السجون
وانه ليس ليس لا علاقه له بالاسلاميين
ويصد التهم التي يقدمها
حميدتين محمد حمدان دخلوا يقول ان الذين
قاموا بمواجهته مواجهه الدعم السريع في
هذه المعركه هما الاسلاميون والبرهان يصد
هذه التهمه بان هذا هو موقف الجيش موقف
مؤسسه الجيش في موقف ما
تشكله مؤسسه الدعم السريع من مهددات للوطن
ومهددات للجيش هذه مؤسسه يرونها في الجيش
انها التساوت في في قواها او اقتربت في
قواها من الجيش الرسمي للجيش السودان
مؤسسه القوات المسلحه السودانيه وبالتالي
لابد ان
يرجع ترجع النسبه والتناسب بين قوه كانت
مسانده فقط قوه عسكريه اسست لمسانده الجيش
وبين قوى الان تريد ان تقف على على مستوى
واحد في الجيش البرهان يقول ذلك ولكن هذا
الموقف الجديد ربما يدعم حجه الذين يقولون
ان الذين يقفون
وراء الحرب في الجيش هم
صله بالاسلامين الموجودين في السجن والذين
خرجوا اليوم بهذا البيان
ابقى معنا اذا المسلم الكباشي ونذكر بهذه
العواجي التي نتابعها منذ بدايه هذه
الساعه في التغطيه مراسل الجزيره يقول
نقاله من النظام السوداني المعزول خرجوا
من سجن كوبر ومنهم علي عثمان طه واحمد
هارون وعوض الجائز واستمعنا قبل قليل
مشاهدينا الى البيان الذي القاه نيابه عن
هذه المجموعه احمد هارون والذي اعلن فيه
الاندماج في معركه الكرامه ضد حكم الاسر
كما قال